let's go to the phones you can call in
on the Friday show via Discord at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord extremely extremely
important stuff to do why don't we go
first to Jason from Toronto Canada Jason
welcome what's on your mind today my
friend
hey David how are you I'm doing well
thank you
uh just actually go I have a couple
questions for you uh one politics
related
um
do you feel that as uh major news
networks are starting to distance
themselves from Trump and all the legal
issues he's currently in are we seeing
the slow demise of him potentially and
his movement or do you feel that that's
still a little bit away
um
as far as uh as seeing kind of the mag
movement kind of dwindle down I think
we've got a long way to go right now
it's not so much that the TV networks
like Fox News for example are stepping
away from Trump but they're giving
themselves other options in other words
they're starting to say hey a lot of
people seem to like desandes they're
kind of building the escape hatch so to
speak but they haven't yet pulled the
eject button if is if that makes sense
that's the analogy I would say however I
think depending on what happens in 20 in
November of 22 in the midterms and
depending on what happens in terms of
the indictments and public opinion
around Trump's indictments if indeed he
gets indicted then you may start to see
things change one interesting thing is
if you looked at predicted which is
betting markets DeSantis is now in the
lead as who is expected to get the 2024
Republican domination nomination based
on the betting numbers if those numbers
continue to go against Trump's favor you
might see an extra acceleration but
right now nobody's really abandoned
Trump they're just giving themselves
other options
yeah that makes sense and just the other
question I have for you as a new father
what are you enjoying most about uh your
experience I I'd say like that you know
essentially day-to-day development and
just seeing how things change so much
from day to day and you know she's able
to do new things and attention span goes
up and ability to just like kind of hang
out without flipping out increases and
it really is I mean certainly from week
to week it gets very different
it's awesome good to hear all right
yeah things are the good uh temperature
here is certainly drop as fall comes in
um but otherwise things are all right
you could I mean I can't I I apologize
for this question but there's no way you
can get a good bagel in Toronto right
that's a Montreal thing
I mean you can get a good big one to
know
it's less known but yeah there's a
couple bagel shops here in the city
they're pretty good wow uh Montreal is
known for it yeah yeah there's some
pretty good uh places here and smoked
salmon and everything's available
yep incredible for sure incredible wow
and you guys have the internet and
running water and everything
oh yeah yeah that's it's amazing we just
got cars a couple months ago that's
awesome very good all right my friend
thank you for the call that was a joke
by the way obviously we we love Toronto
thank you uh no no offense to every
that's those are just jokes everybody
relax all right